so what do you think the future is of
advertised music bridges between the
cultures coming in what recommendations
we have for young influencers and their
appearance market I think influencer
marketing is going to have an incredible
golden year of a decade I think we're in
the beginning of it and I'm very fond of
it I think it's underpriced I think at
the top is overpriced so the people that
moved quickest and have big audiences I
think are overpriced because people
think they're more valuable than they
are you've got to look at engagement
amount of people have a million fans on
Instagram but they don't really have a
community things like that but I'm a
very mean word-of-mouth always worked so
I'm very bullish my my recommendation is
don't run around saying that you're an
influencer think about how to bring
value to your audience
create influence and then monetize it
again we are living through the greatest
era of again you just put it on your
profile and you think you're it that's
like me putting on my profile right now
basketball player oh but I'm not getting
paid by the mix right and so like just
saying you're like the amount of counts
that like hit me up on the end like yo
I'm an influencer I click and like your
800 people follow you yeah but I'm like
no no no you're not an influencer by
definition of anybody's important you're
not so - if you have then your profile
put a word in front of it aspiring
influencer but it's a bet I'm a very
bullish on it
I think it's under price right now I
also see because it's human beings a
scenario where in two or three years
it's going to be grossly overpriced you
just have to follow the market right now
it's under pressure
[Music]